foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm at this meet and greet to meet my
future wife and everything isn't going
so well
these three had some successful guys are
here and it's really putting a lot of
pressure on me
in the back of my mind I just can't stop
thinking that nobody's gonna like a
regular guy like me but I just need to
be myself
because this is the only shot that I
have while I'm in Ukraine
um
so I am Caesar I am a nail technician I
do pedicure manicure
I know
oh you do eyebrow yeah yeah I do eyebrow
too yeah wax arms I can do it for your
end you can make for me okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
perfect yeah we have a match
I feel awesome I made a connection
what's your name my name is Catherine
I'm from Kiev I live in Kiev this woman
Katarina might be someone I really want
to get to know better and now I'm
feeling more confident I'm feeling more
like I got this hello
oh thank you thank you
yeah yeah
we're friends
Caesar right here I see everybody's so
beautiful and and smiles that's nice
yeah you nervous no no I'm okay I'm
ready for love wow
my birthday is uh March 11th March
I really don't like but if my girlfriend
like I fish with her
oh wow
oh I thought you meant fishing
like like this
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
now I'm having a great time there's
something about Ukrainian women they're
tough but also really playful and funny
and that's what I want
[Music]